here we go uh xqc has white he is is he aware the
game star yes he is he is where the game stands
okay and you never know because he's literally
solving puzzles he's doing all kinds of stuff
all the time so here we go the french is on
yes right so so far pretty pretty standard i
mean i like the way that pokemon is playing this i
think her position it's very stable it's not there
aren't really many opportunities to blunder
at least in the next couple of moves so it's
it i think it's a great start for it's about
as good of a start as she could have asked for
yeah okay queen e4 is a threat now from from
x which would be super solid i like queen
d7 though very nice moves you you saw queen
eight was a threat retreats to clean backward
yep very nice this what this is uh this is gonna
do a lot to improve both their cap scores i'll
tell you that they're playing really accurate
chess here that that's actually a very good point
you're right because for pokeman she has made no
blunder so you're right the accuracy is going to
be very high both players are probably going to
be like 90 is my guess yeah and it's funny because
sometimes it's the style of the game that can
lead to a higher cap score everyone i mean okay
it's always if you don't make blunders if you
oh oh oh my oh my gosh he tried to cheese her
he didn't realize it's check he didn't realize
his check he tried to cheese her oh i think
he thought he had a background checkmate if
she takes but if she takes it's just checked
and i think she'll see it too because
it's just like right there in front of her
uh we go minus one 100 here 100
i didn't see it through i think yeah he
thought he had a background checkmate
yeah he said he didn't think it through it's
okay though okay it's done it's fine it's fine
i i want to get that guy out of there it's
so annoying i need we need that piece out
asap oh i could have just threatened to take
queen oh that was the right move there dude
and she goes right back your car looks very nice
very nice by pokeman she spotted the idea of um of
the back rank here and she just takes the juicer
and goes back let's do it i mean she could also
just take right and then free her back rank but
but this would be a super strong find and x
might miss checkmate yeah i totally could see him
missing it he could really tunnel on the checkmate
pattern of the back rank like queen d5 knight g4
or knight c4 to go queen e8 right oh that's
a great point yeah because if she goes here
he'll be thinking about moving his knight
for his checkmate and you could easily miss
your opponent okay she goes queen h3 which
is also quite good and now after king g1
will she play rookie eight that's the that's
the one piece that's not in the game here
will she play rookie eight if she does x x is in
big trouble like big trouble super scary to play
though because we know she's got to be nervous
about the back rank as you talked about it before
right yeah okay she does take which is
which is also fine but now after queen takes
of course it's literally your back rank or go home
you can't yeah you have to be very careful here
now she could also just start checking as well i
could see her checking right like if she checks
the game probably will be a draw i'm guessing
he plays h6 which is okay very nice although now
x is back in the game if he starts pawn goblin
like you said hicaro she might might just settle
on the draw and and just say well you know what
that's how it is yeah and just keep checking right
it could happen i i don't i i mean i don't
know but i think if i'm x you have to be
looking to take the pawn on c5 here but it can
be scary because your king is so open as well
gotta go you gotta go just play g6 here
oh no oh no i forgot i can't oh my god okay oopsie
oh she was oh man it was just a tough
spot yeah brutal oh so unfortunate yeah
you really shouldn't be frustrated about
this game though this was such a great game
yeah yeah i i mean it's it's unfortunate but again
i think that the takeaway from this game is that
she played really well i mean she was in the game
up until up until that blunder with the queen when
she thought for three minutes and blunder she just
resigns the game yeah um we'll just show it again
for those it may be happening too fast the main
point again is that the pawn is pinned yeah right
exactly well pokey is excuse me back at it with
her london system it worked very well against
rubius earlier and uh xqc has has also put the
knight on c6 which is the same development that
ruby has chosen so um now he's taking his time
yeah so far again pretty standard i like what uh
what pokey is doing just bring the knight out
to f3 of course and i'm just keep it rolling
well there she goes and x is on the clock again
but remember if you missed game one he was down
he was down a full three minutes if not more in
game one and ultimately he was able to catch up so
um i i kind of i think you're right he
obviously needs to work on his openings
i also like that he's willing to figure it out
when he feels like he might be losing his way
right i agree now this is a very dangerous
spot for him i think he almost has to take
on e5 with the bishop here there are
very few moves that i think are um oh
no oh no what is that oh no that's terrible oh no
just realizes it now that is terrible take take
oh that is not cool i could
sacrifice a piece here then take take
good idea by him the g5 idea take
yeah g5 is actually a very yeah um
i mean it doesn't work but i
really as creative thinking by him
yeah yeah i think it's very creative to play cheat
i think he should play it actually because there's
a chance that pokeman will not remember to
retreat the bishop why not i have to chat
i i i bugged it good move very nice it
is what it is no he's super resourceful
like in general i don't want to see if she
wins i don't i don't want to discredit her win
okay so i'm gonna ignore it okay but it for the
participant record it was a genuine misclick
okay so actually actually saying that he made a
genuine take for that with knight takes that bad
though wow because he has a fork that's why it was
a bad move that's why i didn't want to go for that
yeah this this actually
opens up my rook surprisingly
the problem with this current game is that this
pawn is blocking is blocking this formation of
my pawns which blocks this glass about what is
strong very nice let's come back to the board
and show the potential misclick there it is one
of the risks sometimes we know that x kind of
clicks on the pieces to see the squares they
move and maybe maybe he was considering taking
and accidentally clicked on the night and that's
what happened so that's that's unfortunate but
but also again very resourceful by him
he was trying to distract the bishop
so that he could take here which would have been
a genius idea but pokey says nope i'm just going
to safely back up mm-hmm yeah this is a big fork
here oh oh whoa she can just take the knight now
i guess we'll see which one she takes
either capture is really really good yep
i but i would take the knight here okay she takes
the bishop completely fine though completely fine
um i really i i like her position i think she's
she's doing very well yeah and obviously she
can take with the age pawn and i agree with you
totally obviously queen takes knight probably a
little more accurate but if she takes with the h
pawn she's still in really good shape and she does
he's very quiet suddenly
and then yes yes pawn up bishop up
bishop takes rook takes skewer queen takes
juicer oh my goodness i see so many moves
i see the moves what about wait a
minute what if i pawn up and quintix
who cares i'll talk about that later
she's plus three but i'm not
scared i i have this i have that
i i yeah it's an investment
okay i play like normally
eight to ten moves ahead i see in the future oh
oh don't trade man that's
dude that's kind of weird bro
oh come on that's not cool man
yeah no i mean i don't think he's gonna trade
i have to go for it wow he
does surprising whatever dude
he sees e5 though with the idea of bishop
f5 which is really really really warm
i can still do it i can still do it
i like it yup oh yeah bad position bad position
but they're all bad positions all of them
it still works will i see it it does yeah okay
so she's gonna i hope she doesn't tunnel and take
get that one so you can think of what oh this
is fantastic oh this is life this is life
this is this is something else i i win this
minus two but this is i don't see her getting
out of this the bunch of blight is going in
take take gigi okay what else what
else whatever she does i yeah it's over
oh what a strong idea it is yeah very
very impressive that he found this
and then we go even okay it's not so bad
she's only down one pawn so it's not it's
not actually the end of the world here yeah
and also after pawn takes pawn you can take
with the knight yeah if e3 e3 just move your
knight you're still winning back a lot of your
right this is gonna come down to the wire here
right so bishop takes bishop so
she takes the pawn oh wait a minute
what about that i missed that that releases i know
he sees it oh wow he sees it and she allows wow
oh wow brutal totally brutal and he is
taking him through his stomach that's art that is
that is legitimate yeah it's over here comes my
absolute one million head late game my
my legitimate advanced brain late game
i mean pogie is still in it though if she can
move quickly that's annoying if she can keep
the time closer i still think it's anyone's game
because again the knight is easier to move than a
bishop but she's got to move quicker um and
try to get back get back ahead on the clock
i could get checkmated right here fast think
check check king moves check okay king moves
upwards check all defended palm moves oh my gosh
we've got to move just go king king three just
move i think you're the king we've been liking it
come on you gotta go you gotta make a
move come on pokey move move the king
if i don't play this right i'm
checkmate well that's not gonna happen
okay king of three e3 nice i got it everything
everything i said i was gonna do i did it
you gotta move what is she
doing seven just to move e1
king d1 yes keep going
oh he found c6 wow no no no no not trim
anymore i can't move now wow there it is
wow so close wow crazy
all right that's is that better
yes yes six zero undefeated yes baby
did it boys
he he should be celebrating because he has worked
his ass off and we see him grinding with puzzles
and playing hard and i gotta i gotta be honest
carl as a guy that we know he had some tough
moments in pog one let's be honest one of the
most viral tough moments of all time right and
look at what he's done hey carl his community
has supported him he has overcome what was a
crazy moment from pogba one and i don't care what
anyone says pokey has a bright future but that was
incredible chess by xqc and he deserves it it's
mixed feelings uh because of a lot of things i
feel like uh since i'm more of an intuitive player
that didn't really uh uh reach back for like a
coaching or whatever it feels good to uh put a
little bit of time in but but see my strategies
and what i thought about pay off in the grand
scheme of things does that make sense it does
so uh it it feels good i think i i could have been
a little bit cleaner but it was really good games
all around today i think all game's really
exciting it wasn't like one-sided or it wasn't
like high accuracy normal standard robotic
play it was i think it was pretty fun today
i do feel like i put up a pretty good fight for
my first pogchamp so i'm really i'm really happy
i just didn't want it to be like a you know
like the snowball or super super one-sided
so as long as it was kind of dynamic fun to
watch i'm happy your pog champs isn't over
yet x can tell you the consolation bracket
is where the party is right yes yeah yeah
yeah it's it's like it's like the brawl it's the
gauntlet and um i think those brackets are spicy
yeah it's always always really exciting uh to
go to the little record i think well ex speaking
of being up on the clock you seem to be making
more of a concerted effort as the game goes on
you tend to your pattern is you tend to get behind
on the clock in the opening you kind of know
that right you get behind and then you sped up
though in these games and ultimately you weren't
down on the clock in either of the final critical
moments what what are you doing to work on your
on your time management in your own chess uh i
think a little bit like uh like a tree right so
sometimes uh when it's when we're about mid game
where you kind of have to make your core strategy
i think of the trunk like the big chunk of
the strategy right okay these these pieces
can move over there and i i try to get a uh
a mental map of what can happen right and
i feel like once i build that core as uh i start
actually playing and i'm alone on the clock
it's easier to get to the branches does that
make sense it's easier to branch out and get
away from the core and and start trickling out
of it i i do think chess games if you know your
end games tend to be kind of like a bell curve
where the most complicated parts are in the
middle um and the parts that require the most
thinking so in that sense very well played xpc
you